joining us now more information
Congressman Jim Jordan and Matt Gaetz
and Fox News contributor Sarah Carter
Sarah all right let me ask all three of
you yes or no am i over the target Jim
Jordan Shawn what I read today in that
in that classified briefing room is as
bad as I thought it was and every single
American citizen should have the ability
to see that information to know exactly
what our FBI was up to will it shock the
conscience of the American people
Shaunie's shocked me I compared it to I
remember the day I walked in two years
ago and the Benghazi committee walked in
and saw the immunity agreements that
were given to people in the Clinton
investigation I didn't know they'd given
him to I open up that folder and I
looked down when the Justice Department
official slid that folder over to me on
that table and look down and see they
gave Cheryl Mills immunity during the
Clinton investigation Clinton's chief of
staff her lawyer today when I read the
material I had that same shock feeling I
was like wait a minute this actually
happened from our Justice Department and
this FBI that's how serious this is
that's why we're calling on every bit of
that information we got to see today to
be made public for you to see for
journals to see most importantly for the
American people to see Matt gage you saw
these materials today you agreeing with
Jim Jordan because it sounds like a few
people decided they wanted to fix not
only they fixed it so Hillary wouldn't
get in trouble on the email server
scandal we know felonies were committed
she fixed the primary rigging the
primary sounds like they're fixing and
rigging here a general election or to
overturn an election and you know I mean
whatever word you want to describe that
fixing shrugging a coup I don't know
yeah you are describing the very
elements of a palace coup and after Jim
and Mark Meadows and many others of us
reviewed the intelligence information
today it is abundantly clear that the
entire Buller investigation is a lie
built on a foundation of corruption and
what is so important is that we get this
information into the public square the
best disinfectant for this corruption is
going to be sunshine and that's why Jim
Jordan and I have joined many other
members of Congress and calling for this
information to be released for the
review of all of the American people
you know Shaun when you've been on this
show each and every night
making claims about the bias and the
corruption and the deep state people
have accused you and your guests of
being tinfoil hat folks lone voices in
the wilderness this critical
intelligence information will vindicate
the claims that have been made by so
many and it is absolutely essential that
we share it with all Americans that's
what we're fighting for in the Congress
is it a fair statement that what we've
been the onion we've been unpeeling
we've been over the target the whole
time
congressman gates well Shawn we can't
get into the specific information but I
can tell you I am as certain as ever
that the claims we have been making our
accurate claims that there is
intelligence information that backs it
up and that there has been a real
attempt to undermine this president and
it has come from the scariest of places
some of the very people we've been
talking about will be exposed and the
key reason that all Americans need to
see this memo is that it names names it
says who was involved with who how
different actors and characters we've
heard about interacted with one another
and that is the type of information that
we need all Americans to see immediately
Sarah Carter you have been all over this
all day what can you tell us about your
reporting well I can certainly say that
my reporting coincides with what
congressman gates and congressman Jordan
are saying and I think it's far worse
than what I believed could have happened
and from what I've been told
senior government officials may be
removed from office may be fired I don't
know how far this will go I also want a
lot of those questions answered Shawn
who was in relationship to who when it
came to these fights Awards how did they
operate with one another what were these
really egregious actions that took place
that only this memorandum and report can
tell us and I've been watching my
Twitter feed and I've been watching
Twitter all day and I'm seeing hashtag
released the documents hashtag released
the documents everywhere the American
public deserves to know the truth here
it is absolutely essential that we
understand what was happening and this
was a duly elected president of the
United States of America and if people
within our own government we're trying
to use
that and change the trajectory that the
American people need to know all right I
agree with you on release the documents
The Wall Street Journal tonight in an
editorial they're demanding the same
thing
congressman Jordan yeah we deserve to
see this you agree with that and how
soon will we be able to get our eyes on
these doctor prot yeah great question
Sean here's the process chairman Nunez
and the Intelligence Committee in the
house he can bring the committee back
together they can have a vote if a
majority of the committee votes to
release these documents the executive
branch gets a certain amount of time to
review them if the executive branch
gives the thumbs up they go public so
this could happen real quick
chairman Nunez is committed to getting
this information what Democrat wanted
you to see it well no they did it but I
can after you read it and you see and if
they're playing partisan politics you
can see why they didn't want us to see
that and you can see why they won't want
the American people but as Matt Gaetz
said as Sarah say this is something that
needs to be out so the this should never
happen in a country as great as the
United States of America and we need
every single American take a look at
this and see what exactly their
government did their law enforcement
division did this is this is that kind
of information and it needs to be public
as soon as possible well it sounds to me
like a lot of people congressman gage
need to be fired and investigated yeah
that's right
I think that this will not end just with
firings I believe there are people who
will go to jail I was very persuaded by
the evidence and it also became clear to
me why Chuck Grassley and Lindsey Graham
felt it so important to refer this
matter for criminal prosecution you
don't get to try to undermine our
country undermine our elections and then
simply get fired so I think there will
be criminal implications here and we
have to underscore the point that you
and Jim Jordan just made every single
Democrat on the Intelligence Committee
voted against even allowing other
members of Congress to see this
information so you know they're gonna
fight against release to the American
people what are the Democrats so afraid
of why don't they want the American
people to know the truth about what was
going on with the government how that
impacted the president has transitioned
his campaign and it just seems
interesting to me that Democrats don't
want us to know what the entire basis
was in the first place for them all our
probe they wanted you drag this out
through the midterm elections to try to
embarrass
president and distract this Congress
from the critical work we've got to do
to save this great country the details
do you conclude that Muller the whole
issue of Trump Russia collusion never
should have come up does Muller need to
disband and this was a lie
built on corruption built on a sham the
entire investigation is a fiction it's a
fallacy and when the American people see
how this began when the Americans see
people see how different people
interacted with one another how
organizations were infected and
infiltrated and subjected to tremendous
bias of individuals and how that really
played out I think that every American
will understand how absolutely ludicrous
it is that we continue to allow them all
our probe to go forward it needs to end
because the entire basis is a lie I know
from my sources Sarah that they're
saying this should result in the
immediate firing of Lisa Paige of Peter
struck of Bruce or also Andrew McCabe I
have some questions
where does rod Rosenstein stick in this
equation the one that appointed the
special counsel did he cuz we now know
the dossier the phony Clinton Walton
paper dossier that that was used for the
FISA warrant all of this leads to Muller
that never should have happened because
it was on opposition party propaganda
then everybody what's what Comey
what's his involvement here where does
he stick where does mother's
investigation stand based on your
reporting tonight well apparently when
this document goes public which I
believe it will I do believe it will be
the unraveling of the Moller probe and
I've been hearing that from other
sources and Shawn this was all about in
the beginning remember Trump Russia
collusion Trump Russia collusion now we
know from what we've been hearing from
the sources from the congressional
members who have seen this memo that the
collusion appears to be between certain
members of the FBI and the DOJ and the
Hillary Clinton campaign and that the
foundation of this was all based on lies
not only do I want to know what Rosen
Stein who was actually the Department of
Justice was withholding that information
for a long period
of time you know and then finally gave
it up to the house intelligent rot
Rosenstein sign-off an extension of this
FISA warrant do we know we we don't know
that yet I have not had the privilege of
seeing the actual classified document of
course the congressional members have
but I do not know the answer to that yet
but I would like to know how Sidney
Blumenthal plays into all of this
because I think that's going to be a
very telling telling revelation when all
of this comes out do you have can you
give us any information not giving us
any details congressman Jordan but about
call me about Muller and I'm very
interested in rod Rosenstein and all of
this no I mean look there are certain
people who can sign that finds an
application only only certain people can
at the Justice Department do that so we
don't know who did and after you go read
this material what we feel we get we can
eliminate this quickly it wasn't Jeff
Sessions he was recused either
Rosenstein or I believe one other person
has the ability to there's only handful
of people at FBI and justice who can
sign off on one who did that we don't
know what we do know is what we've been
talking about this should go public and
also we know there is more to come
because the investigation that the
Intelligence Committee is not complete
thank goodness for what Devin noonas and
his committee are doing and the push
they did on the Justice Department to
get these documents in the first place
so but there is more information their
investigation is not complete when it's
complete then you're gonna see the
judiciary committee do even more
Comey had to know all of this was going
on didn't he well we again we can't talk
about specifics who knew what what we
read today what we read today though was
a memo that compiled information that
they've got that they presented to
members of Congress to look at we called
for members of Congress to be able to
see this material just a few weeks ago
today we're calling on all Americans to
be able to see this material so they can
see what really took place
hashtag release the document release all
the background associated with the
document thank you all for being with us
thank you